foreign
[Music]
okay so shall we start
yeah it's okay so Baba can you give me a
small introduction about yourself
thank you for the opportunity uh my name
ishwar and I've done my b-tech from
computer science branch I got 7.8 cgp in
my colleges and I got a 78 in my 12th
standard
regarding technical skills computer
science is present in every field as
everyone knows so I spent the last four
years owning my Technical and software
skills in computer science I've learned
programming in Java C C plus plus
JavaScript which I'm learning right now
I've learned database Technologies like
SQL MySQL mongodb I've created some
projects like Library management quiz
app and calculator and there are other
small projects that are made I think
that they're in my CV actually you can
find the GitHub links for those there
are small small projects are there as
well apart from that I think what has
helped me the most is participating in a
lot of hackathons
both online and offline they really
helped me to you know be aware of what
my peers are learning and kind of kept
me ahead of the curve so that I can keep
myself updated with technology and apart
from technical skills regarding personal
life I have few Hobbies I love to play
football I love
reading as well and I love watching
science fiction movies
so they think that wraps up everything
about me okay okay so my next question
is what are your long-term goals
uh my long-term goals would be to gain
as much experience as I can in my domain
that is additionally I plan on what I
learned using these initial formative
years from a uh for my next
few years which can help me move into a
more senior position so uh using
previous expense will help me so that
when opportunities come for promotions
or any other opportunities come then I
can make use of it if I use the correct
skills as such having a long-term Vision
in while starting out a career in
corporate can be very helpful so that
you can apply yourself in the right
direction and be aligned with that plan
I think that's my long-term goal as of
now at least okay good can you state the
difference between hard work and smart
work
I really both are necessary in a person
one person needs to understand how when
to use Smart work and when to use hard
work uh but I think uh what really
differentiates is using less resources
and less time to achieve the same result
by putting more effort in high yielding
activities rather than
mindlessly slaving away I think that's
what makes the distinction between hard
work and smart work uh more prominent
it's like uh I think there's a quote by
Steve Jobs or some uh no I'm sorry that
that quote is from Bill Gates where he
said that I will find a lazy person to
do a difficult job because he'll find an
easy way to do it
so I think that pretty much sums it up
the difference between hard and smart
work okay good very good uh now let's
start with the technical questions sure
first treat yourself in Java out of 10.
uh I think I rate myself for 6.5 out of
10 in Java
okay okay good now tell me what are jdk
jvm and JRE
please explain about them
sure let me go one by one first would be
the GDK which is the Java development
kit software package of jvm and Jr it
contains both it jdk basically provides
the standard edition of the Java
application programming interface
second was jvm which is the Java virtual
machine it's basically converts the
program into bytecode which basically
means it converts a user-friendly syntax
to machine language that the machine can
Java machine and The Interpreter can
understand okay
third one would be the JRE which is the
Java runtime environment and provides
the libraries and the resources for jdk
to execute the Java programs I think
that's the main distinction between
these three yeah right right so uh can
you tell me does Java include pointers
um no Java does not include pointers can
you just please explain
okay so basically the first point of
pointers are the main benefit I would
say would be to uh for uh taking a
memory allocation purposes so Java
already has jvm like you mentioned
before so jvm automatically takes care
of memory allocation so there is no
real-time use case as such and when it
comes to a side benefits or pointers uh
like uh clearing memory because it just
points to a specific memory for clearing
memory Java also has this garbage
collector so all in all there is no
particular use case in majority of the
cases in Java where we would actually
require a pointer that is not something
already being done by Java right itself
okay so you are saying Java does not use
pointer in real time programming right
correct whatever all those benefits or
pointers that they offer in C Java takes
care of it on its own okay okay good uh
list some Java 8 date and time apis
I think the Three core apis would be the
local date local time and local date
time
okay
uh what is the default method and when
does it get used the default method
actually involves an implementation and
it is found in an interface the method
adds new functionalities to an interface
while preserving backward compiler
backward compatibility with the classes
that have already implemented that
particular interface I think that's a
main purpose of our default method in
general
okay okay
uh okay can you mention the main classes
implementing the list interface
first I think the most important will be
the linked list which basically linked
elements with no index and arraylist
which can be indexed then Vector which
is similar to array in some aspects and
it also can be indexed and the fourth
would be a stack stack which follows the
last in first dot methodology of the of
data structure
okay you just said array can you explain
what is an array
array can be referred to as a collection
of items which are stored in a
continuous memory locations it's it must
contain items of the same data type when
it organizes data in a related set of
values that can easily be sorted
searched manipulated
Etc so basically it helps create a
collection of similarly uh defined
variables uh values in a single array
variable okay so we cannot store any
other data types in Array right yeah all
elements must be of the same data type
there cannot be any mix and match okay
okay good can you explain what is in
linked list
it's kind of similar to array but it
refers to linear data structure in which
the elements are not necessarily stored
in a continuous manner like they are
stored in an array so it's basically a
sequence of nodes with each node
pointing towards the next node then
that's how it forms a chain-like
structure that's how it's different from
an array okay mention the link list
supported by Java
a Java supports to a singly linked list
and W linked list single linked lists
where each node points to uh stores the
data and references to the next node
whereas the W linked list has points to
two different ones which is the one
before it and the one after it these are
the only two that are the job okay good
uh can you tell me what is regretation
what is recursion
you must have read about this
yes uh recursion would refer to a
function calling itself under a
particular terminating condition follows
the last in first out methodology and it
makes use of the stack uh data structure
okay now please tell me which sorting
algorithm is best according to you
uh I don't think any sorting algorithm
can be considered the best okay there
are many like bubble sort selection sort
balloons or Radix or all those things
are there but I don't think we can turn
any one of them as the best because they
all have different use cases if the if
there would have been a single best
sorting algorithm all of us would be
using only that one right so I don't
think there's particular best they are
fit for the specific type of data
structures where it performs the most
efficiently so no I don't think there is
particularly in my opinion I don't know
the best sorting algorithm okay right uh
what is the difference between system
dot out system.e Double R and system.in
to error
can you just explain about it
yes uh system dot out and system.err
represent the monitor by default and
this can be used to send data or results
to the monitor so system.out
specifically is used to display normal
messages and results basically the print
function of the Java family
system.err is used to display the error
messages and setup.in third refers the
input string which uh is saying pushing
object actually which by default
represents standard input device which
in almost 99 of the cases is a keyboard
okay now can you write down the syntax
on how to create a linked list and a
vector in Java you can just type it in
the chat box
uh sure
I'll actually create a new object okay
author linked list class here yeah
[Music]
I just want to see the logic only okay
okay
uh this is to create only the object
variable for the linked list I know
actually uh
[Music]
okay
it's quite similar to the
link list object but we have to add two
more parameters which would be the size
and increment okay
let's type it here only I think I have
shared
okay
okay fine
so my next question is how do you get
the highest number that exists on a list
just write a code here only okay should
I just put a sample uh yeah yeah I just
want to see the approach you are using
sure okay I'll just write the code again
highest number that exists on a list you
can take any random list
I'll create a list with integer
value
[Music]
foreign
list
okay
foreign
yes okay
I think that should be enough like
should I elaborate more or do you think
it's yeah it's fine it's fine I just
wanted to see the approach that you're
using okay now can you write how to do
the reverse in string in Java
reversing a string right yeah okay
you can just take a string hello and
just reverse it okay I'll put it in a
variable
[Music]
I'll create a
dummy variable named reverse where the
actual reversed output will be stored
first I'll take the length of the string
and store it in the length variable like
I just shared next I'll start a for Loop
uh there's a single line in the body
I'll just
write that down separately okay
so you are taking basically it's taking
all the elements and it will keep adding
them to the
reverse variable that I had declared
before and the next step would be to
just print out the final reverse
variable
I think that will reverse the string
completely okay
okay fine
now
how many objects will be inside the hash
map
um there can be two elements with the
same hash code but when two elements
have the same hash code Java uses the
equals to further differentiate so there
can be one or two objects depending on
the content of the objects
yeah okay okay now give an example how
to create a hash map
in the chat only okay so like a sample
yeah
okay sure
I'll first import the necessary
libraries
this is the hashmap library then I will
report
the mapping Library
I'll start the main function okay
the class declaration
um now I would go with
[Music]
and now I'll start the body of the main
function
if you need time to just think of the
approach you can take time with this
which I thank you so much
um
I'll be putting two string values
declaring a new hash map right now
hmm
[Music]
uh declare the new initialize the new
hash map then I'll start storing data in
these hashmaps
using the put function
this would be the first element and next
would be
similarly I'll put another element just
to show
okay you're taking the car names okay
so I've already just put two in the hash
map so now I can I can keep adding more
but I think if I just adding I can just
talk just add two or three only yeah so
these two are done so I can just print
out as
obj
and just basically close the main
function that's it
I think this will
okay just let me read once
it's good
okay can you please tell me what are
your greatest strength and weaknesses
okay I'll start with my strengths I
think my ability to work well in a team
is one of my finest assets I have a
strong sense of self-motivation and I'm
a very quick learner
whatever assignment I get I usually uh I
tend to finish it very diligently and
preferably ahead of schedule
I don't know if there are any standout
weaknesses as such but one thing that I
believe can be improved about myself I'm
a people skills indulging in
conversation with co-workers and people
I'm not very comfortable with or talk
regularly with but I have been working
on that a lot and there has been a lot
of progress and there is going to be
more for sure moving on
I think that's the only thing that I can
count as a weakness okay good uh so
where do you see yourself in five years
okay uh I think initially I would first
uh like to grow my skills as a team
player in the first few years at any
organization uh then understanding how
upper level management works and then
ultimately uh get up earn a managerial
position
most likely handling a very high output
team and being able to Mentor a bright
group of people who who are prepping for
their next step in their career just
like I would have done by them
now tell me why should we hire you
uh have a very strong sense of
motivation I really push myself to
improve and learn more I am very
open-minded as well and I pick things up
rather quickly like to solve
difficulties and hopefully solve
roadblocks for our teammates come as me
okay apart from that from apart from
spills perspective additionally I
believe that the values of this
organization and mind are very
compatible so that's why I think I
believe that this job in this position
will support my interests and present me
with enough engaging and exciting
opportunities that will help me advance
myself and the company so that's why
frankly I'm very excited about this
chance okay okay good okay so thank you
baba this is all from my side if you
have any questions you can ask me
I think uh I really have only one
question uh can you tell me about a
company and the more importantly the
daily responsibility is that I'll be you
know asked to ahead on a day-to-day
basis okay so wherever right now I can't
tell you everything but we are a
software company we develop software
according to the needs of the clients
and everyone is Young and energetic here
so the environment is also very good
okay I think that's all I needed to know
okay okay thank you so much for your
interest
we'll let you know the results very soon
okay so thank you so much I will
definitely look forward to hearing
okay
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here